- Des enfants en pleine santé
qui font de graves hépatites,
des transplantations, des cas
qui s'accumulent. Les grandes
agences de santé publique
lèvent le drapeau jaune :
un nouveau problème est
apparu sur leur radar.
La maladie est parfois
fulgurante. La jeune Britannique
Lola-Rose, en pleine forme
à 3 ans, a failli mourir en
l'espace de quelques semaines.
C'est la transplantation d'une
partie du foie de son père,
Alan Raine, qui l'a sauvée.
Jusqu'ici, on a rapporté 190 cas
d'hépatite de ce genre
dans une douzaine de pays.
Presque 10 % des enfants ont dû
subir une transplantation.
Au Canada, la santé publique
enquête sur plusieurs cas
d'hépatite aiguë d'origine
inconnue chez des jeunes, mais
sans donner plus de précision.
C'est peu en chiffre absolu,
mais suffisant pour inquiéter
les spécialistes.
Dr JESSE PAPENBURG, spécialiste
infectiologie pédiat., microbio.
- Il semble vraiment qu'il y a
un signal qui nous indique
que quelque chose de différent
est en train de se passer,
et on voit une augmentation
du nombre de cas d'hépatite.
- L'hypothèse la plus étudiée :
une souche d'adénovirus,
un virus commun souvent
associé à un simple rhume.
75 % des enfants en étaient
porteurs. Mais on est loin
d'une certitude.
- Le premier pas, c'est
justement d'essayer de chercher
le plus d'informations
possibles. Et pour pouvoir faire
ça, il faut que les cliniciens
à travers le monde soient
conscients du problème potentiel
afin de pouvoir rapporter
les cas.
- Un autre coupable possiblee p,
mais indirect : la pandémie.
Dr FERNANDO ALVAREZ, hépatologue
et pédiatre, CHU Sainte-Justine
- Je pense aussi que l'effet que
les enfaut les enfants
les plus jeunes, n'ont pas été
aussi exposés à différents
virus, incluant des adénovirus
circulatoires, dans les deux
derniè, ça facilite
maintenant l'apparition d'autres
virus et la circulation
d'autres virus.
- Selon les spécialistes,
nts devraient surveiller
l'apparition de certains
symptomes, comme la gastro-
entérite, un changement
de couleur des selles et de
l'urine ou une forte fièvre.
ité des enfants touchés
avaient moins de 6 ans.
Ici Normand Grondin,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.